all right Peach yeah Peach uh where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally
where am I from I've lived in like 30
different places so
um
I was born in Hialeah which is Miami
Florida
um very poor neighborhood Opa-locka area
is where my mom had us
um
my mom was a workaholic I just remember
her working all the time like
from sun up to sun down she was braiding
hair in our living room everybody knew
about my mom in the neighborhood so
um she was doing a lot of people's hair
and
she was a single mother taking care of
me my brother and my two sisters
um
I would describe your childhood
I would say that it was rough
um was that around
yeah no my dad wasn't I mean my dad was
like in and out like my mom was a single
mom so
um
my dad like he came and goes as he
pleased but I mean he was there in our
lives just not as often as he probably
should have been
what kind of kid were you in high school
um in high school I was kind of like a
loner I was kind of weird because
my mom she was very religious so we grew
up in a Christian
strict household when I was nine years
old we actually moved to a farm which
was like in Northern Florida like in the
middle of nowhere and um the farm was
very isolated and it was a Christian
farm so there were other like Christian
families there and
um there's like a lot of rules and
restrictions like we couldn't wear those
girls we couldn't wear shorts or long
pants or
um
shirts without sleeves stuff like that
like it was a very strict schedule we
were always in the field like everything
that we ate on the farm we grew so all
of us kids are always like in the field
from sun up to sun down and we had like
a strict schedule of
um prayer every weekend praise and
worship Church
um Bible study every week like every
single day was something like we would
get up extra early like 6 a.m to do
prayer everybody on the farm together
would like gather to the Tabernacle and
have every meal together and everything
so it was just like coming from that
kind of environment into a public school
system when I was 14 it was like a
culture shock because like the kids were
normal like they were cooler like I was
wearing clothes from you know the thrift
store and [__] Goodwill
so
you know I didn't have a lot of friends
I was I wasn't bullied but nobody really
[__] with me like that
your childhood is free of any abuse
yeah my mom used to abuse us
um I ran away when I was 17 because like
one day she had beat me with the belt
with the middle part of the belt and she
slashed my face open and like after that
I was like I'm not doing this [__] no
more and my sister had ran away for the
same thing like my little sister
um
my brother as well like she was she was
just very angry
she had good intentions like my mom
loved us but she was very she had anger
issues
so she would take it out on us a lot
you graduated high school
I did
how old are you now I'm 26 now 26. what
have you been doing since he graduated
um ever since I graduated I've been like
when I graduated honestly like that's
when I ran away from home I was couch
hopping a lot I was um
I was living with friend after friend I
was sleeping with guys just to have
somewhere to sleep like
um I was just trying to stay out of the
streets for a long time like it was
really bad to the point where like I was
so depressed and overwhelmed with
everything that it was like I was either
gonna kill myself or
um go to jail at least they feed you in
jail or join the military sign my life
away to the military that's what I ended
up doing I ended up going to join the
Navy so
I joined the Navy for like a month and
they kicked me out because they found
that I have double vision so I was in
the same [__] up situation again
um you know being homeless and stuff but
it wasn't anything that was abnormal
like we were homeless me and my mom like
we were homeless ever since I was 14. we
were homeless for like a few years like
in homeless shelter programs and [__]
like that
so
um but yeah when I got kicked out of the
Navy she was going I went back to my mom
and she actually was moving back to
Miami so I just moved back to Miami
where her started working like you know
a little nine to five jobs and then
um it's like I could never catch up So
eventually I ended up like making Fast
Money like stripping and stuff like that
and stripping his ass off some some of
those problems yeah I was I've been able
to like save up a lot of money from
dancing
um right now it's like to the point
where I'd rather model than dance
because like stripping comes with a lot
of [__] like I'm kind of tired of
that [__] it's like it's becoming it's
just tiring after a while bro like
so all I've been doing is like mainly
modeling like video vixen [__] and
stripping a little bit less now so
but yeah the I mean the money is good
with stripping it's just very draining
sex work gets to you emotionally
yeah it does it does because a lot of
times like you're disrespected and it's
like when you speak up you have no voice
like people don't listen to you like
when you tell them to stop doing certain
things to you like when you're dancing
like a lot of guys will get very excited
and they're like
they'll violate you so
and it's like I'm a girl so if I tell
them to stop or like
you know you don't want to tell them in
like a
in a bad way or like piss them off
because you never know what a guy can do
like
it could get really bad so
you're putting yourself out there as a
sex object so you're going to be
objectified yeah for sure
as is doing that kind of workout in the
way of your
your love life personally
um
not really like
guys love freaks like guys love
strippers at the end of the day like
I've never had a problem dating any type
of guy like
my boyfriends love what I do they accept
it yeah
even though you're out there
you know you're probably guys are
touching you at the club yeah they're
they're okay with that yeah I mean
sometimes when I tell them like a horror
story like you know [__] like
fingering me or like you know doing some
wild [__] they'll get mad but it's like
what can they do like they're not with
me every day at my work so it's like
you have to just take it as they come I
guess you see this is a short-term
career for you yeah I don't plan on
Dancing forever
I do it because it's like it's quick
bread and it's easy
and you know like it's good for now like
if I want to save up something for
something or if I need something I'll do
this but it's not like my end career
goal no what is your what is your goal
um the goal in life is to invest in real
estate and properties I want to get the
buildings it could be residential
buildings or commercial buildings
um
I want to be able to have like a
sanctuary for my family so that we're
never homeless again because that was
like a very very big part of my life
it's like we spent a lot of years being
homeless and like struggling so I want
to be able to have like something that I
can leave for my family
so we don't have to go through that
again
it'd be nice yeah
are drugs a part of your life
yeah when I moved to California from the
farm
um
I was introduced to a lot of drugs and
sex and violence and [__] like that
I mean it's California so you think that
happens faster in California than it
does in Miami
not now no I feel like everybody's on
drugs in Miami it's very similar to here
what drugs do you see in Miami
y'all are more so with the crystal meth
in California I don't see too much
crystal meth in Miami
um we pop a lot of pills like you know
Molly Ecstasy [__] like that like
everything's pills or powder
like not so much heroin and meth and
[__] like that
being a stripper is
also sometimes a way for girls to
to to turn dates
to turn what dates with guys
I haven't like I wouldn't call myself a
prostitute because I I've never
um it's never been like set up like
prostitute work like I'm not standing on
the street so it's like but there's been
times before like when you know guys
offer me a certain amount of money to do
certain things and
um
you know I've done it so
in my situation it's always been like a
sugar daddy type of thing not really
necessary a prostitute doing like
prostitution work but I have had a few
sugar daddies where I have had to have a
sexual relationship with them in order
to get my knees
what did you learned about men from
doing this kind of work
um
man just
they only think with one thing like
their dick like that's it they just
wanna guys are just very horny creatures
they just want to have sex they just
want to feel good like
they just want to be humped on it's just
they just over sexualize us women and
that's all they think about is [__]
[__] [__]
coming from a girl who's working in a
strip club or is that just in on the
street as well
that's everywhere you think it's
everywhere yeah
that's just the male nature
what do you go through emotionally
just in general whether whether you're
working in a strip club or
or not
[Music]
um
um I mean it has its ups and downs like
if I'm making a lot of money I find that
I'm very happy
and when I have bad days or when I feel
like I'm broke I'm depressed like it's
like night and day like
it can go from me being like ecstatic
and like in a great mood and being
bubbly Peach and then like the next day
it could be to be wanting to kill myself
like it's very
flip-flop and money money solves the
problem sometimes yeah
what's your dream you need a rich guy
um I've met a few Rich guys but no I
want to be the rich guy you want to make
the money yeah good for you
I don't want to have to depend on nobody
for anything like I want to get it by
myself
but your greatest fear
um be worried about now
at 26 years old
[__] I just want to make this money
that's all that be on my mind for real
like
the fear is going broke
I'm just very motivated and tunnel
vision not making money that's your
greatest strength
um my my greatest strength I would say
is like my love and my healing that I
have that comes with that like I love so
much and I love so hard that it can heal
you
it's a great quality yeah
do you believe in karma mm-hmm
how does karma play out in your life
um
honestly I feel like I'm blessed like I
feel like I'm blessed and I don't bad
things don't really happen to me like
that like I know a lot of people that
get it worse than me so I just feel like
I'm one of God's chosen ones and
I'm always like protected wherever I go
there has been times where I have dealt
with Karma like if I ever wish bad on
somebody which I barely do but it's been
like a couple times where like I've
literally wished bad on someone I felt
like after those particular times like
something really bad has happened to me
and then I'll think about like damn I
did wish bad on somebody so that's why
this is happening and sometimes I'm like
[__] it I'll go through the bad [__]
just so that something bad will happen
to that person
so
it just depends on the situation you've
been in love before
yeah
I'm scared of Love Now
you get hurt yeah I hate I hate the
feeling of like the whole breakup thing
and just keep being heard and cheated on
and lied to like that [__] kills me that
[__] tears my heart like so I'm good off
that [__]
at least for now
you were working in clubs for how long
you can do it for how long
um
I think I started off doing like House
Parties that's that was like two years
ago and then I started like I became a
stripper stripper like a year ago so
it's been a year now I've been like
dancing dancing you see it changing you
in any way
yeah it desensitizes you like being in
that lifestyle and in the industry too
like with modeling and stuff like seeing
how guys are and it just makes you look
at people different I don't trust nobody
it makes you not want to trust anyone or
let anybody get close
you just want to like protect and guard
your heart from like all the evil in the
world because the world is so evil it's
got to be difficult to be around people
you can't trust all the time
all the time and to be your own friends
too A lot of times what advice would you
give to a woman who's thinking of doing
that
of stripping
um I would say if you do it know why
you're doing it have a goal set don't
lose focus of your goal
um and get out of it as soon as you
reach your goal get the [__] out what's
your biggest regret or what do you wish
you had done differently anyway
um
um I would my biggest regret is
let giving myself to men like
the amount of men that I've given myself
to and the kind of people I've given
myself to like sexually that is my
biggest regret
how has that affected you
I mean I've forgiven myself for
letting myself be slutted out I guess
like I've forgiven myself from it I've
moved on I try not to think about it it
makes me cringe like when I think about
like all that [__] but
does it affect yourself worth
self-esteem yeah it does it really does
it do mm-hmm
yeah especially like now that it's like
a body count is like a thing like that
determines a woman's value like a lot of
guys when I first meet them that'll be
like one of the first questions they ask
like oh what's your body count or to be
funny they'll throw that out there like
what's your body count like I'm like why
does it matter bro like do you know your
[__] body count no like
give us a different
judgment is Harsh around women than for
men yeah it is and it shouldn't be that
way
I know a lot of guys that are [__] too
so
you want to have kids one day
yes and no like if it happens it it
happens but am I trying to have a kid no
[__] no
try to find the right guy
yeah or try to find the right career for
yourself yeah I need to be like more
established and um
yeah have my [__] together before I
think about having kids and then it's
like thinking of the pain of having kids
too that's what really [__] with me
it's like I can't bro like
shout out to the moms because I don't
know how you do it like your whole body
rips open and then you never look the
same afterwards just like
I love my body too much
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
[Music]
the most important lesson I would say is
to not
not give yourself fully to somebody like
and be careful who you are giving
yourself to
and I would say like you know guard your
heart and
it's been like times where I've been
like man [__] everything [__] everybody
nobody gives a [__] about me so I don't
want to give a [__] about them like and
you know just stop being nice and just
being rude because everybody else is
rude but it's like you can still be nice
because that's who I am in my heart like
I am you know very giving and nurturing
and loving person like it's just I have
to
be picky choosy with who I show that
side to you know what I'm saying if that
makes sense like don't just show
everybody that because that's how you
get used up and I've been abusing used
boy like
because of how pure my heart is
so I just have to be careful like who I
show that to
you all right Peach thanks thank you so
much for sharing your story you're
welcome
lots of luck thank you thank you very
much